Європейські прапори та плакати із закликами до ЄС
часто можна побачити на мітингах у Каталонії.
Багато хто з них не розуміє:
чому Європа не втручається?
"Ми почуваємося кинутими напризволяще
з боку ЄС.
Їм слід було якось відреагувати
на поліцейське насилля минулої неділі."
На засіданні Європарламенту
в Страсбургу депутати від Каталонії
теж висловлюють критику.
"Відбулося однозначне порушення
основоположних прав у Каталонії.
Застосування насилля проти мирних демонстрантів
є порушенням наших конституційних прав,
європейського права.
Тобто це вже не є суто внутрішньою
справою Іспанії."
Лідер Каталонії Карлес Пучдемон
уже неодноразово звертався до Євросоюзу
по допомогу. Брюссель опинився
у складній ситуації.
"Єврокомісія не може змусити
іспанський уряд до переговорів.
Адже це внутрішня справа уряду в Мадриді
і це закріплено у європейських договорах.
Єврокомісія вже дала зрозуміти:
вона не втручатиметься у внутрішні справи
країни-члена."
У Страсбурзі заступник голови Єврокомісії
Франс Тіммерманс підтвердив свою підтримку
Мадриду.
"Якщо закон не подобається,
то слід працювати над тим,
щоб змінити його,
але не можна його просто ігнорувати."
Уряд Каталонії заявив,
що вже найближчими днями
оголосить незалежність від Іспанії.
ЄС може змінити свою нейтральну позицію,
якщо ситуація далі загострюватиметься.
Але Брюссель все ж дуже сподівається,
що іспанцям та каталонцям
вдасться порозумітися без втручання ззовні.